[Musik]
ein feiertagen indien menschen kommen zu
einem tempel und kühe und rinder zu
spenden
manches tier hat eine beschwerliche
reise hinter sich ist der kaiser hat
schon oft solche bilder gesehen
[Musik]
wieso stellt das immer schlechter
zustand sind im mangelernährung und der
ganze stress von werner breunig vor dem
match die schweizerin nicht
professionelle tierschützerin
immer wieder reißt sie noch hingehen um
kühe und andere tiere zu retten
wissen wir seit der schweizer wofür
retten
ja das maxxi insbesondere will natürlich
alle schweizer ski landkreis heiligen
coach einigen in die schule zu holen
grundsätzlich weiß diese gut geschützt
es gibt einen politischen akt wo ganz
viele vorschriften beinhaltet aber es
wird energiekosten und die gläubige die
natürlich sehr oft so genanntes nicht
wüssten was sie darstellen wenn es die
für den abgang
die indische staatlicher kaputt nahm am
bengalischen mehr
ok
seit tagesanbruch ist ist der kaiser
ohne frühstück unterwegs die 50 jährige
ist gründer in der weltweit tätigen
tierschutzorganisation etappe
der hauptsitz ihrer partnerorganisation
leiser arbeitet mit lokalen
tierschützern zusammen
diese kümmern sich um den welten das
wird ganz ganz viel kummer ist gründer
und leiter der tierschutzorganisation
indischer partner
er hat rund 80 angestellte
ein großes anliegen ist ihnen das wohl
der kühe
ziel ist ein markt wo kühe rinder und
kälber verkauft werden
das ist punkte vor dass sich alles
vorher nur wenige tiere sind hier wo
sonst hunderte zum verkauf angeboten
werden
oft würden sie dann illegal geschlachtet
ich weiß selbst nicht wie in der
richtigen nicht gehört in hand und als
vorrat man kann damit jetzt mehr
notorisch normal ist können wir dieses
vorhaben war in der casino stadt las
dass ich mir das flex leistungen des
staates sind das nur soviel hier
transportiert werden wie auch erlaubt
sind
das sagte da ich das mach' euch dass sie
hier nicht locker werden ablagert werden
sie immer da
ich denke alltag gibt denkt jung india
hat ihres chefs tierschutzgesetz zitiert
der vergangenheit werde es ganz ganz
strenge voraussetzungen um in der 50 uhr
überhaupt auftritt werden ist aber
sicher galt ihr leid verursacht werden
ist ganz lange transportbedingungen dass
nur bestimmte art für zum beispiel
testet verladen werden
diese bestimmung ist die kalte werde wo
aber einfach übergangen werden zwei
männer wollen mit ihren körpern das
weite suchen
durch sie haben die rechnung ohne
tierschützer im report nur um gemacht
wem gehören diese tiere
wo ist das futter und das wasser für die
tiere wieder an
wir nehmen die tiere jetzt mit ich werde
deine knochen zerquetschen finde sie
fest oder ich zeige dich an
ihr werdet beide hinter gitter wandern
schämst du dich nicht illegale geschäfte
mit ihren zu machen was hast du mit den
tieren vor
wir wollen die tiere verkaufen zeigt mir
lieber eine identitätskarte zeigt sie
mir müssen wir immer wieder hierher
kommen um dich anzuweisen den tieren
futter und wasser zu geben
interessiert wirklich also da habe ich
okay dass ich sehr erstaunlich viel
trauer hat hosen verständnis in indien
und wird so viele traurig vom zählt er
sehr geschätzt
frautv spiel sagen der hat mich
unendlich angelangt und dann konnte gott
geknutscht also die handschuhe angst vor
den frauen die polizei stein getroffen
sie beschlagnahmen die kälber die
situation bleibt ruhig
das ist keine selbstverständlichkeit
erzählt prädikat ja es ist gefährlich
wir sind schon oft attackiert worden und
könnten es jederzeit wieder werden
zweifelsohne direkt neben dem markt
befindet sich das polizeigebäude eine
sitzung mit den behörden ist angesagt
der direktor des veterinäramtes hat ein
offenes ohr für die tierschützer
gleichzeitig kennt er aber auch die
situation der bauern
die meisten der bauern sind arm für sie
ist es nicht einfach tiere zu halten
die lebensbedingungen sind schwierig
hier diese gegend ist ihr trocken ab
dezember gibt es kein grünes gras mehr
torjäger lebensbedingungen sollten die
bauern das gesetz einhalten sagen die
tierschützer
das gilt ja auch hier wo sich jeder und
jede kennt ich werde einfach zwei
schritte und das ist dafür der behörde
innerhalb der letzten drei vier jahre
hat sich einiges getan
heute habe ich sogar einen leeren
wassertank gesehen
das nächste mal wird dann auch wasser
drin sein
geht hier sind beschlagnahmt wollte die
firmen jetzt ihnen hohe lammers hof in
qualität als aufgabe minute was ist das
für sie führe moment das ist ein
glücksmoment wie mit einem absoluten
kraft nicht wieder alle vier räten
umgesehen jeden tag hunde die für tiere
in not allein natürlich am schluss so
ursachen dass man einmal gab vor von
neues herz klosterhardt zu verleihen
auch konkrete weitere spuren
dann taucht plötzlich ein mann auf der
sich als besitzer das exterior ausgibt
erfordert sie zurück doch in wahrheit
handelte sich um den metzger cdu hat ihn
erkannt was wirst du mir vorspielen
liebe zu die kühe gehören dir gar nicht
sonst wandert ins gefängnis
der metzger ist vertrieben jetzt können
die kälber und rinder in den gnadenhof
transportiert werden
die tierschützer haben mehrere verstöße
gegen das gesetz festgestellt dass sie
überhaupt sie sind genervt ich muss
jetzt auch alle die regelverstöße ich
bin meine brust vieles so viel sind dass
man rechtzeitig beschlagnahmen ob sie
greifen mit dem buch zitiert lore hat ja
ein kleines zelt sie halte dann hätte
jetzt kein problem und sie kaffeepulver
mit ja absolut ich setzen so minimal und
damit jene die heute bin ich sehr
wichtig dass man recht auf der hand dass
so wenig schutz man mit der materie
haltet ihr körper bestraft
[Musik]
das ist eine von insgesamt zwei
gnadenhöfe die von der lokalen
tierschutzorganisation betrieben werden
finanziert werden die farmen durch
spendengelder ist der kaiser überweist
rund 100000 franken jährlich nach indien
gelder die in der schweiz gesammelt hat
allein auf diesem hof leben rund 1000
tiere ein kleines paradies für viele
arten die gerettet wurden
bis er eines natürlichen todes sterben
aber das ziel ist eigentlich dass man ja
system andere dass man über ghana muss
dauernd kette die gärung was wollten sie
die alle zu stehen dass man wird
weghofer der nutzer sechs die
formatierung nutzen ich glaube fest er
aber ich vor 160 jahren hat man einen
sklaven und mittag war auch dass das
andere
wenn das frauenstimmrecht es ist alles
im prozess braucht aber irgendwann bin
ich überzeugt das müsst ihr immer so aus
unterboten weser wo man muss nur
betrachtet sondern als labor klappen
reise und ihr team wollen den bauern
neue wege aufzeigen
ziel ist es ihren ertrag zu steigern
ohne tierleid zu verursachen
aus dem urin der kühe wird hier
beispielsweise ein alternatives
heilmittel hergestellt man hat einen
größeren wirtschaftlichen gewinn
die bauern müssen wissen dass wir profis
so größer ist als mit milch ja es reicht
es infiziert früh am morgen etwas von
dieser medizin einzunehmen bewahrte ich
vor krankheiten
ich sah schon auf der straße leute die
sich das mittel über den kopf schüttete
ja über den kopf das mag ich nicht
[Musik]
esther kaiser hat jura studiert
zudem ist die ausgebildete
verhaltenstherapeuten katzen
vor zehn jahren gründete sie die
international tätige
tierschutzorganisation nicht ab seither
ist die professionelle tierschützerin
sponsoren würden ihr einen fixen lohn
ermöglichen sind zack die bohne
spannende sich nicht die normale bank wo
ihnen hund von normal spenders sondern
sind lied wo wirklich expliziten wähle
dass ich heute in der schweiz tätig bin
schon als kind fühlte sie sich zu tieren
hingezogen
sie will sie vor ihrem größten feind
beschützen der menschen war wieder wie
groß sie sind neue bietet ihre
ausbildung im labor das herzschlag
primärer für dir ja sie brauchen mich
meine hilfe nötig und sie kann ein
wahnsinnig viel sie kann das eine
bedingungslose liebe
sie nehmen ein limerick sie akzeptieren
handke vorurteil und sie brauchen sie
brauchen sie hilfe lage zu missbrauchen
zu nutzen zu und sehen als nötiger denn
je 20 straßenhunde wurden schon
eingefangen um sie zu kastrieren und
gegen tollwut zu helfen
davon würden auch die menschen in dieser
kaputten profitieren sagte schweitzer
seit beginn der infektion vor acht
jahren sei kein mensch mehr an der
gefährlichen infektion erkrankt
das ist der grund dass jetzt so marc
sand oder wie sind die kosten pro jahr
5000 kinder praktisch kaum jemand kann
katze kastrieren es wissen doch als ich
sagte ich nun hier und jetzt sind die
bereits trainiert wurde und sich quasi
das der startschuss zum eine
kastrations- programm über
hunderttausend katzen wurden schon in
der schweizer und der geister
federführung kastriert und geimpft
und ich bin beeindruckt wie jener
vorschriften halte besser als die
restlichen schweiz nicht erlaubt
ja
[Musik]
wo immer sie ist überragend exit
tierleid so einfach ist auch dass uns
eine wenigstens pizzeria lediglich die
wasser gehen was ist ihre wahl
als er seinen erfolg das war natürlich
mache ich akzente die ausschreibung habe
mai in hannover kalt und feucht ich bin
mit merken das nicht angepasste gruben
ja schon realisiert dass er bis muss
sterben damit ich das von außen und das
kann ich ganz ganz verschwunden
das hat mir überhaupt nicht ganz nach
vorne gemacht und sagt das ist ja das
wird man wahrscheinlich nur die
rechtslage aber es gibt sicherlich
extrem sendet ich würde sagen ich bin
eher von sechs land und das macht
natürlich ein mensch im eigentlichen
frank und damals auf den spiegel folgt
der umfang viele fragen was sie gar
nicht wüsste dass ich jede wo natürlich
gesorgt der bis zur anderen
auf dem dach ist zum weniger leiten
ursache macht man anderen schlacht
gewisse automatisch wohl nicht bereit
ist den weg beschritten
dass sich die natur für das auch
beherzigen sie ganz herzlich
eigentlich will sie ihre tätigkeit platz
bisher ist mit dem schuss das sich mit
der dpa so zu stellen dass auch hier
lebenspartnerin der schweiz denkt so wie
sie und unterstützt sie im tierschutz
hochbetrieb im hindu tempels im
hartschalen der statiker kaputt nahm
wann immer man teile die bühne zu
bringen die gläubigen ihre halbe am
gampel und wenn dir spannt das ist sehr
heuchlerische will eigene schmerzlich
aber loswerden verboten in indien
jungtier schlachter sind einfach ist
auch die jeder einfach verdammt
spannendes über die handschuhe im tempel
sind jedoch nur die indischen kyrill
kommen alle anderen tiere werden oft
illegal geschlachtet das wissen viele
gläubige nicht deshalb werden sie von
den tierschützern am eingang zum
heiligtum abgefangen bringt ein kalb
darüber spende den tempel lieber geld
als ein tier das wie kommt zu bauen die
respektvoll mit den tieren umgehen
[Musik]
doch einige rennen das sind zu schwach
für den transport
[Musik]
ein ortsansässiger tierarzt ist
eingetroffen ist der kaiser hat
veranlasst ihn zu rufen hat mühe die
blutbahn zu finden um die infusion
zulegen
die schweizerin ärgert sich
und ich als quelle wer sich jahren
entgegen wieso haben sie ist für mich
hier raus
moderat heißt nicht dass man hier lebe
ich hier aus kanada war für sie komme
sie die hilfe kam zu spät
das stört
[Musik]
an diesem frühen morgen geht es um die
rettung einer vom aussterben bedrohten
art die basta schildkröte wurde durch
umwelt und fischerei stark dezimiert
platz
heute so leicht
bin so glücklich mit dem projekt nur
gerade eine von tausend gezüchteten
schildkröten wird überleben ist kaiser
weiß dass ein gerettetes tier die welt
kaum verändert aber für das eine tier
verändert sich die ganze welt und dafür
lebt sie